- And I'm, like, about to cry,
and he's just like, "Hold on.
"I'm getting married
next weekend in Pennsylvania,
"and he'll be there.
Why don't you crash my wedding
and fuck Mark Parker?"
[dark electronic music]
♪
[cheers and applause]
- Hello, everybody.
Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening."
I'm your host Ari Shaffir,
and today all the stories
are about nostalgia.
[cheers and applause]
You guys'll absolutely love her.
Please give it up for Miss
Annie Lederman, everybody.
[cheers and applause]
- My story is about
my happy place.
You know,
we all have that happy place
that we can go back to
whenever we're in dark times,
that place from our childhood
that just brings us back,
you know,
makes us feel happy.
My happy place was Camp Swatara,
my Quaker camp that I went to
in upstate Pennsylvania.
And I remember, like,
when my dad and my mom
would put me in the car,
and they'd drive me up.
I remember the butterflies
I'd get when I started to get--
we'd approach, you know,
the entrance.
And they would drop me off, and
it was just, like, so amazing.
There was just, like,
bonfires and friendship
bracelets and fucking dreams.
Like, I remember
the pizza bagels,
like, every single thing
about it.
And then there was Mark Parker.
Um...
Oh, he was just, like,
the cutest counselor ever.
He was so hot.
He had an eyebrow ring.
He knew, like, every lyric
to every Dave Matthews Band song
that you know he played
on acoustic guitar
at every fucking bonfire.
And he could fuck up
a hacky sack.
Like, he was just...
he was so hot.
Like, I was, like,
I didn't even know what--
why my underwear was wet.
I just knew that,
like--
I knew two things
about that underwear,
that my mom had written
my name in it,
and that it was soaking wet.
I was, like, Baby Horny.
I was like, "What are you?
I love you, these feelings."
Ugh, and all the counselors
were so cool,
and I fucking loved that camp.
Um, camp did not
love me back as much.
I was just completely invisible,
not cool at all.
Like, when you got older,
when you were, like, 13, 14,
they would start--
the counselors would start
to wake up the cool girls
at night and, like,
bring them out to smoke weed
and drink.
And so I would--they would,
like, wake me up.
I'd be like,
"Hello. Yes?"
And they were like,
"Do you mind moving over?
Sarah's getting down."
And when you graduate
from the camp at 14,
you can apply to be
a counselor,
and all I wanted in my life
was to be a counselor.
I mean, they were, like,
living the dream.
They were just, like,
so awesome.
And I was, like, I--you know,
I would love to be
a camp counselor
at Camp Swatara,
but I'm not gonna get the job,
so I never applied,
because I was, like, I--
you know,
I can't handle that rejection.
It'll be too deep,
you know?
So instead,
I graduated from Camp Swatara,
and since I couldn't,
you know,
smoke weed and drink
with the counselors,
I decided to just, like,
go back to Philadelphia
and just smoke and drink
with real criminals,
and I just became, like,
a horrible juvenile delinquent
and was just stealing cars.
Like, my life just, like...
[whistles]
went completely downhill
from there.
So I went to some
really dark times
and really struggled
with alcoholism and drugs
and really got fucked up,
and I remember a moment
just staring into a mirror just,
like, "What have you done
with your life?
You used to be a camper."
And I wrote in lipstick--
I wrote on the mirror--
I wrote,
"Remember Camp Swatara,"
and I left it there for,
like, years,
like, just years and years,
I never cleaned that mirror,
and I would just look at it
in my dark times,
and it would bring me back,
and I could really, like,
close my eyes and remember,
like, the morning bell,
and I could remember, like,
the pig that they had
at the little farm.
I just remembered
the tire swings and the zip line
and, like,
the lake and everything,
and Mark Parker.
I mean,
it was just so incredible.
So then a couple years later,
I quit drinking.
I moved to New York
to start doing stand-up comedy.
And I am feeling good
about myself.
And right then on Facebook,
I get an invite
to a Camp Swatara reunion,
and I'm like, "Oh, my God.
"Here's my time to shine.
"Here's my time to show them
how cool I was.
"I wasn't invisible.
"I'm Annie Lederman,
an open mic'er
living in Bushwick."
[laughter]
But I'm just, like,
so excited to go,
and I look at it,
and I'm working the weekend,
and I can't go
to the fucking reunion,
and I'm, like, devastated,
and I go out--
before I go out, though,
I--
I take the opportunity
when I realize
that I can't go to the reunion
to just friend request
every counselor I ever had,
just everyone across the board.
Don't give a fuck
if they accept me.
I'm just throwing it
out there anyway.
And I go--I go onto the subway
all bummed out,
and I hear--from behind me,
I hear someone go,
"Annie Lederman?"
And I turn around, and it's
this guy, Dan McFarland,
who was one of my
camp counselors,
and I'm like, "Holy shit,"
and he's like, "Oh, my God,"
and I'm like--first of all,
I'm shocked he remembers.
Like, I can't even believe
that he remembers me.
I'm, like,
maybe I wasn't invisible.
And he goes,
"Annie, this is so crazy
"that I'm running into you
right now,
"because I was just talking
to one of the other counselors.
"He was talking about
your Facebook.
"He had looked at your Facebook,
and he's, like,
was talking about how hot
you are."
And I was like,
"Me? Hot?"
I was like, "But who--
who was the counselor?"
And he was like,
"Mark Parker."
And I was like, "Oh, my God!
Holy shit!"
I was like, "I have wanted
to fuck him my whole life.
"Before I knew what fucking was,
I wanted to fuck this guy.
"I've measured every guy
against him.
"I'm in love with him.
"I have loved him every day
since camp.
"Give him to me.
Where is he?
Put him inside me now."
And he's like, "Oh, he doesn't
live in New York anymore,"
and I'm, like, about to cry,
and he's just like, "Hold on.
"I'm getting married
next weekend in Pennsylvania,
"and he'll be there.
Why don't you crash my wedding
and fuck Mark Parker?"
[laughter]
And I'm like, "Yes."
- Yeah!
- I'm like, "Is Jesus real?"
Like, I'm like,
"What is going on?"
I'm like--I mean, fate,
fate, fate, fate.
I'm, like, this is just, like,
gonna be the best experience,"
so I tell everyone.
Like, I'm going to bodega guys.
I'm going on the subway.
I'm stopping homeless men.
I'm like, "Here's a quarter.
I'm gonna fuck Mark Parker."
Everyone knows.
I'm, like, this is gonna be
the best day of my fucking life.
Not only was it amazing
that this had happened,
but it's also, like,
I was wrong about who I was.
Like, if I had applied
to be a counselor,
like,
I might have gotten it.
Like, I may have missed
my fucking opportunity
to live
this fucking incredible life,
because how would he know--
like, he wouldn't--
losers don't get stopped
on the fucking subway.
Invisible people don't have
Mark Parker saying they're hot.
Like, so I go
on his Facebook page,
and I write, like,
"You're a CILF,"
and then in parenthesis
in case he doesn't get it,
I'm like,
"A counselor I'd like to fuck,"
and then I'm like,
"That's not enough,"
so then I go on his--
into his messages,
and I'm like,
"Hey, Mark, let's fuuuuuuck."
And he writes back,
like, "Cool.
"Yes, absolutely.
I'm down."
Um, so I pack my fuck bag.
It's just a suitcase
filled with underwear,
obviously no condoms,
'cause I can party,
and then I, like, you know,
I pull my little suitcase,
and I go in, and I'm just,
like, I mean,
I can't even, like,
describe to you how I felt.
I'm, like,
I can't wait to meet
this fucking handsome-ass
fucking man.
Like, I just--I just
remember him being, like,
so tall and dark and handsome
and, like,
amazing and talented
the way he fucking played
"Crash Into Me."
I mean...
[laughter]
And I'm, like, and just to see
all the counselors in general,
like, to see my heroes again,
and I, like, you know, I, like,
but through the door,
and it's after the wedding,
because when you crash
a wedding,
you don't go for the ceremony.
You go to fuck,
obviously.
So I go in, and I look around,
and I'm like,
"Who are these old people?
Oh, these are my counselors."
I'm like, "Oh, holy shit."
They're all, like,
balding and fat and, like,
pregnant, and I'm, like,
it was like if 1990 froze...
But they got old as fuck.
[laughter]
So I'm, like,
it's cool, whatever.
Mark's gonna be hot.
I'm, like,
I'm looking for him, right?
And before I can find him,
this woman I've never met
comes up, and she goes,
"Oh, my God.
Are you Annie?"
And I'm like, "Uh-huh,"
and she was like, "Oh, my God.
Are you Mark's Annie?"
And I'm like,
"Well, it's--I guess."
And she was like,
"He's so excited you're coming.
He's been talking about you
this whole time."
And I'm, like,
that's when I realized
I'm the
second-most-eventful thing
that's happening at this wedding
besides the nuptials.
Like, everyone's like, "This
girl's gonna come to fuck Mark.
"This is amazing.
Mark's getting fucked."
So then, you know,
the dork sea parts,
and there he is.
And let me tell ya,
he still has the eyebrow ring.
[laughter]
He had, like,
those long fingernails
like he still plays guitar,
which by the way, guys,
just trim them.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I don't need to know
whether I have HPV
from your fucking fingernails.
And I'm just, like, holy shit.
Everything that made him cool
in the fucking '90s
makes him so
unmotherfucking fuckable now.
[laughter]
Keep in mind, I've quit
drinking at this point.
I'm sober as fuck.
Like, there is no way
to drink him hot.
Like, this is my lot in life
at this point.
There's no other reason
I'm at this wedding
than to fuck Mark Parker.
Like,
I'm there to get it.
And he comes over,
and he's like, "Hey, girl."
And I'm like, "Noooooo.
"Oh, he's also got
gay voice?
"Jesus fucking Christ.
I got nothing
to work with here."
[laughter]
So I'm like,
"All right, I hatch a plan."
I'm like,
"I am gonna get him so wasted
"that he passes out,
and it's his fault
he doesn't fuck me," right?
I'm like, "That sucks.
I was looking forward to it."
So it's--the plan's working,
right?
He's starting to bobblehead.
He's got Cookie Monster eyes,
you know.
He's fucking about out.
And I see him.
He pops a pill.
And I'm like, "Ambien?"
"No, Adderall, motherfuckers."
So now he's just--
he's just there for me, guys.
And I'm, like--and he was,
like, so nice you know,
so I had to fuck him.
I had to!
What was I gonna be, like,
that's the whole reason I came,
I couldn't be all of a sudden,
"I'm not ready.
I'm not ready."
I aggressively was like,
"I'm gonna fuck you.
"I'm gonna fuck your dick.
"I don't know if you know
what body part I'm gonna fuck.
It's your dick."
Like, at least we'll
go back to his,
like, nice room in this nice
bed and breakfast.
No, he didn't have
his own room.
I fucked Mark Parker
on the pullout couch
in another counselor's room.
[laughter]
So the sex was great.
Just kidding,
terrible.
[laughter]
At one point,
he goes down on me,
and he looks up,
and he goes, "Mmm, delicious."
[audience groans]
Like he's making a Yelp review
of my pussy.
[laughter]
Like, "Mmm, delicious."
Can we both be shot?
Can we be taken out by snipers
right now?
Like, someone should die
after someone says that.
So fucking humiliating.
And I'm just, like,
in my own personal Vietnam.
I'm like, "Oh, my God.
How do I get out of this?"
So I close my eyes, and I try
to go to my happy place,
but all that's in my happy place
is, "Mmm, delicious."
And I'm like, "God damn it!
"I fucked my happy place.
Oh, my God."
But I, like,
after the deed is done
and everything's been
Wet-Napped up...
[laughter]
I just, like, go to bed feeling,
you know, grossed out.
Like,
I ruined camp for myself,
but at least I saved camp
for him,
and he now goes to bed knowing
that he's preserved this--
you know, this crush
and this relationship
that he's always imagined
having too.
So I go to bed a hero,
and then I wake up
from those sweet,
sweet dreams
to Mark watching me sleep,
which is always delightful.
What a way to wake up.
"Ahh."
My life is in danger,
terrifying.
Just to have your mistakes
just right in your face,
like, "Ahh!"
The glistening
from the eyebrow ring, great.
[laughter]
So he--you know,
he's staring at me, and I go,
"Uh, hello," and he goes,
"You know what?
"I was looking at you,
watching you sleep,
and I'm realizing, I think I do
remember you from camp now."
[audience groans and laughs]
I'm, like, about to cry.
He didn't remember me
from camp.
Yes, I was invisible.
Yes, I was a loser.
Do you know who I was to him?
Some fucking stranger that
friend-requested him on Facebook
and then was like,
"I'm gonna fuck your dick."
And then I fucked him.
I was just the chick
from Facebook.
[audience groans and laughs]
So I guess the moral
of the story is,
don't rape yourself
with someone else's body.
[laughter]
And never go back
to your happy place.
Don't fuck your happy place.
My only issue
with telling this story
is that Mark is, like,
so nice, you know.
He's, like,
such a good person.
And I'm just so afraid
he's gonna see this,
you know,
and I'm gonna feel so guilty
and have to fuck him again.
You guys,
thank you so much.
[dark electronic music]
♪